dans la chasse aux faux seins faux
info ou intox avec anthony st léger
bonjour en tenons jean-raphaël bonjour à
tous et avant de développer le principal
sur vous allez nous montrer une vidéo
oui effectivement je voudrais qu'on la
regarde ensemble cette vidéo peut-être
s'agit-il de quelqu'un que vous
connaissez à faire regarder
bonjour je suis la nouvelle
présentatrice de france 24
retrouvez moi chaque jour dans paris
direct pour informations fiables et
vérifiées
liberté égalité actualité alors est-ce
que vous avez déjà rencontré cette
nouvelle collègue dans les locaux de
france 24 et non pour cause elle
n'existe pas effectivement les
téléspectateurs ne la verront pas à la
fiche de paray direct prochainement sur
un email
effectivement c'est ce qu'on appelle un
dip fait qu un effet spécial qui permet
d'animer un visage ou aussi de modifier
une voix tout simplement pour lui faire
dire ou faire ce que l'on veut et pour
ce qui est de l'extrait de ce soir que
l'on a vu cette assez simple on va
regarder ça ensemble nous l'avons créé
en quelques minutes seulement grâce à un
site internet le site internet c'est
celui ci regarder santé via s'appelle
c'est un site qui permet de fabriquer
des vidéos incarnés par des acteurs le
voilà et vous voyez on peut choisir tout
simplement le ton un peu plus actualité
ou un peu plus commerciale vous voyez
que l'avatar change il vous suffit ici
est bien de remplir le script tout
simplement le texte que vous voulez
faire dire à votre acteur vous cliquez
ensuite sur continuez et vous donner une
adresse mail et en quelques minutes
seulement vous recevez la vidéo en
question alors ce n'est pas le but de
manipuler ce n'est pas le but premier de
cette de cette de ce site c'est utilisé
principalement selon son pdg à des fins
de formation et d'éducation également et
le pdg de la société qui a d'ailleurs
affirmé aux observateurs de france 24
que son entreprise prenait les mesures
adéquates vis-à-vis de ceux qui en
abusent ray et qui les utiliseraient
justement à des fins de manipulation
moi je vous dis dans cinq hommes
auraient remplacé dans ça c'est sûr car
effectivement il s'agit là on vient le
voir d'une blague co2 si utilisé à des
fins de désinformation dans un contexte
beaucoup plus sérieux prenons par
exemple le rappelle l'exemple
des tensions entre paris et bamako vous
en avait parlé dans votre journal qui
ont franchi un nouveau cap aujourd'hui
avec l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de
france au mali depuis plusieurs semaines
il n'est pas rare de voir sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment au mali des
vidéos avec des voix robotique
automatise évoquant à la fois la
politique intérieure malienne que la
présence française dans le pays une page
facebook celle-ci relais habituellement
des informations musicales elle a plus
de 80 mille abonnés et ces derniers
temps elle s'est spécialisée dans ce
type de vidéos elle a par exemple publié
pardonnez moi en décembre dernier une
vidéo celle-ci montrant le philosophe
français bernard henri lévy et elle
assurait cette vidéo qui conseillait des
terroristes malien malien cette vidéo a
été vue plus de 900 mille fois sur
facebook c'est une fake news puisque la
vidéo en question est prise à partir
d'une photo et la photo n'a rien à voir
elle a été prise au soudan en 2017 et
sur cette même page facebook le dernier
exemple en date c'est celui ci on va le
regarder ensemble on y voit quoi dans
cette vidéo est bien on y voit un décor
de journal télévisé regardé je sais pas
si on peut voir voilà le décor le voici
décor rouge le journal 13 heures ça
paraît très officiel le présentateur qui
affirme donc que la france a versé de
l'argent à des partis politiques maliens
pour qu'ils ne participent pas aux
assises nationales de la refondation
c'était en décembre dernier et cette
allégation est les bases et on va le
voir sur une être faussement assez
grossièrement rédigé une lettre fausses
qui a circulé courant septembre au mali
ma formation fauche tout comme le
présentateur effectivement puisque le
présentateur que vous avez vu et bien
c'est jay z qui appartient donc à cette
société synthèse ac72 je vous parlais
voilà le jeune en question
alors nous on dans l'exemple qu'on a
pris n'a pas rajouté de fonds s'est
concentrée contenter de modifier la voit
donc voilà le présentateur télé en
question jay z alors bien sûr lady paye
qui ne sont pas nouveaux mais ils ont
gagné en sophistication au fur et à
mesure des années évidemment pour
devenir vont le voit très réaliste très
crédible il faut préciser aussi que ce
type de deep funk est assez rare tout de
même de manière générale ils sont
beaucoup plus flagrant grossier beaucoup
plus artisanaux finalement aussi mais on
a vu que ça c'est assez accessible
puisque c'est un site internet nous on
l'a fait en quelques minutes c'est
gratuit et une version payante propose
évidemment beaucoup plus de
fonctionnalités alors évidemment si vous
entendez dans une vidéo ou une voix un
peu robotique un peu automatisées
prudence vigilance ça doit vous êtes
justement sur la voie la fox merci
anthony st léger info ou intox avec
anthony rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans moins de cinq minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris diane